- As you come in, I'll
start to welcome you.
I'm Paul North.
And these are the Franke
lectures in the Humanities
at the Whitney Humanities Center.
This is a series called the
value of Marx's capital,
which I'm convening along
with my co-conspirator,
Paul Reitter at Ohio State
who is the valiant translator
of a new translation of
Volume I into English.
The series is also a companion
to an undergraduate seminar.
So the undergrads have
valiantly gone through Volume I,
with a kind of a microscope
and they've survived and
if they have survived,
they're in the audience tonight.
I have to read this.
The Franke lectures are made possible
by the generosity of
Richard and Barbara Franke,
and are intended to present
important topics in the humanities
to a wide and general audience.
I need to thank as I always do,
Alice Kaplan, the director of
the Whitney Humanities Center,
Sandra Malan-Bowles and
Leana Hirschfeld-Kroen
who have done behind the scenes organizing
and Audrey Leak who is our tech genius,
making things stay on track.
I know a lot of you have been here.
So you've heard this before.
We will have the presentation
from our speaker.
Then, tonight we're going
to have a short response
by our friend and another co-conspirator
Michael Heinrich, who's back to discuss
a little bit with Fred Moseley,
and then we'll open to questions,
hold your questions and
put them into the chat.
When we get to that period,
otherwise, I will lose them.
I'm doing my best to
keep everybody in order.
It is a great pleasure
to introduce Fred Moseley
who is an emeritus professor of economics
at Mount Holyoke College,
where he taught Marx and
Marxian economic theory
for many years.
He has published extensively
on Marxian theory
and the Marxian analysis
of the US economy.
His latest book is "Money and Totality,"
a macromonetary interpretation
of Marx's logic in "Capital."
And the end of the transformation problem,
we can celebrate that that was from 2016.
He also edited and wrote
the introduction to
the English translation
of Marx's economic
manuscript of 1864 to 65.
These are the manuscripts that
are newly translated into English
that became Volume III of
"Capital," edited by Engels.
He's a longtime member
of the Union for Radical
Political Economics,
and served as program director
for the URPE sessions at the annual
convention of the American
Economic Association
for 10 years.
I'd like to welcome Fred Moseley.
Fred, I'm gonna give the
microphone over to you.
- Well, thank you very much, Paul.
And thank you for the invitation
to participate in this very
interesting and innovative,
I think, seminar.
I've watched some of the other sessions
and it's been really an inspiration
to hear the different
perspectives on Volume I.
Thanks also to the Whitney Foundation
for the generous funding for this seminar
that is really quite a contribution.
Both the theory and the
pedagogy, I think Marxian theory.
Well, the paper I'm gonna present tonight
is different from my original intention
and the one I sent to Paul in September
just to explain a little bit.
That paper was an overview
of all of Volume I
with a focus on these
two important aspects
that I discussed in my recent book,
The monetary nature of
Marxist theory in Volume I,
and the macro nature of Volume I,
mainly explaining the total surplus value
and the economy as a whole.
However, listing to the presentation
by my old friend, Michael Heinrich,
in his presentation in the seminar,
I thought I would add a
few comments to my paper,
and then I kept adding
more and more comments,
and eventually I had a whole new paper,
obviously very stimulated
by Michael's opportunity
to engage again with Michael
and it decided I would
discuss this new paper
in my presentation, both because
that's what I'm most
interested in at the moment
and I also hope you
will be more interesting
to participants to dig deep
into the all important chapter one,
and to consider these two
somewhat different interpretations
of this important chapter.
Some of you may have read the other paper
and have questions about that,
I would of course be happy to discuss.
And let me say, even though Michael
and I disagree about some aspects
of interpretation of Marx's
theory of value and money,
in chapter one, I wanna say at the outset
how much I appreciate
Michael's contribution
to Marxian scholarship and how
much I have learned from him
especially about the MEGA.
I first learned about the MEGA
from Michael in the early 90s
from a 1989 paper he
published in Capital and Class
about the manuscript of 1861, 63,
published for the first
time in the MEGA in the 80s,
and almost unknown at the time,
among English speaking Marxist
and I was very excited, including myself.
I was very excited to learn about MEGA.
And much of my research since then,
has been related to the
MEGA in one way or another.
So for me, and for many
other English speaking
and German challenged Marxist,
Michael, has been a very important kind
of conduits from the
German Marxian scholarship,
and especially the MEGA to Anglo Marxist,
which I appreciate very much.
You could say today, maybe Michael
has been a sort of super spread
in a good sense of the term
of German Marxian scholarship.
So my talk will focus on chapter one,
then, by all accounts chapter one
is a very difficult chapter.
And for that reason, very controversial.
Yeah.
Marx said in the preface
to the first edition,
if you remember,
beginnings are always
difficult in all sciences.
The understanding of the first chapter
will therefore present
the greatest difficulty.
"I have popularized," he says,
"the passages concerning
the substance of value
"and the magnitude of
value as much as possible.
"The section and the form of
value is the most difficult.
"My favorite preference,
actually, the Volume I
"is to the French edition."
I don't know if you've
noticed this or not.
But he says, "the method of
analysis which I have employed,
"and which had not previously been applied
"to economic subjects,
"makes the reading of the
first chapter rather arduous.
"And it is to be feared
that the French public
"substitute the American public,
"always impatient to come to a conclusion,
"eager to know the connection
"between the general principles
and the immediate questions
"that have aroused their passions
"may be disheartened because
they cannot move on at once."
Marx says "this is a disadvantage
"I am powerless to overcome,
unless it be by for warning
"and for arming those readers
who zealously seek the truth.
"There's no royal road to science,
"no easy road to science,
"and only those who do not dread
"the fatiguing climb of its steep paths
"have a chance of gaining
its luminous (indistinct)."
So you probably have found
chapter one to be a fatiguing climb.
And I hope there will also
be some looming assignments.
So first, I wanna briefly describe
the overall logical
structure of chapter one
that Marx alluded to in these prefaces.
And the key point to understand
about the logical structure
is that there are three main aspects
of Marx's concepts of value.
It's a complicated concept, right?
And these three aspects
are substance of value,
the magnitude of value and
the form of appearance.
Value and so, I will briefly
describe each one of these.
First the substance of value, right?
This is the common
property of commodities,
that determines their exchange values
with other commodities,
which Marx of course assumed
to be the abstract labor
required to produce commodities.
So, that's the substance of value,
the common property that determines
the exchange value.
Right?
Then the magnitude of value
is quantitative, right?
The quantity of the
substance of value required
to produce commodities,
the quantity of abstract labor required,
contained in commodities which Marx called
the socially necessary labor time
contained in commodity, right?
So substance magnitude then the
form of appearance of value,
the money and prices, the
observable phenomena, right?
The substance and magnitude of value
are not directly observable as such,
in units of abstract labor,
therefore, commodities
require an observable form
of appearance, so that the magnitude
of each commodity can be compared
and equated with the magnitudes of value
of all other commodities.
And this observable form of appearance
is ultimately derived as
money and money prices.
Sections one and two of chapter one
are about the substance
and magnitude of value,
section one is the most important.
The title of section one
is substance of value,
the subtitle, substance of
value, magnitude of value, right?
In section three is about
the form of appearance
of value, its title is the
value form, or exchange.
The part I wanna emphasize is that there
is a strict causal relation
between these three aspects of value.
Causal relation is that the substance
and the magnitude of value
are derived and presupposed
in section one, one and two,
and then the form of appearance of value
is derived from the
substance and magnitude
of value in volume three.
So I think it really helps us
to understand this
overall logical structure.
And then the whole chapter I think,
becomes more intelligible
and perhaps less of a fatiguing climb,
excuse me, my voice isn't
what it used to be at 19.
Okay, so then one more
kind of introduction,
just to kind of preview and
identify four important,
controversial issues,
involved in chapter one,
in the interpretation of chapter one.
So the first issue is in section one,
Marx's derivation of abstract labor,
as the substance of value
as the common property of commodities,
that determines their exchange values.
And the issue is, what's the
logic of this derivation?
And is the derivation value acceptable?
Second issue with respect
to the magnitude of value,
defined in Volume I,
is this magnitude of value of property
of each single individual commodity,
or is the magnitude of value a property
of multiple commodities
possessed jointly together?
Actually, I learned from an
email from Michael yesterday
that perhaps we don't disagree as much
as I previously thought about that.
And so I'm happy about that
and will not concentrate on that as much.
Third issue.
And this is really, I think,
the most important issue both
between Michael and myself
and the general Marxian scholarship,
is the magnitude of value
determined entirely in production,
the production process
or does it also depend
at least in part on circulation
and demand for a particularly product.
And unfortunately, just the derivation
in section three of money and prices
is the necessary form
of appearance of value.
And for me, the main issue here is
that this very important section
is often overlooked or
not discussed in any depth
and I think it's important
in part in large part
because of it's difficulty and it seemed
as so boring and detail,
but it's very important as we shall see.
So, I will now review
kind of section by section
my interpretation of chapter one
with substantial textual references,
and then I will discuss
at least one aspect
in particular of Michael's interpretation,
this third issue is the determination
of the magnitude of value in
production and or exchange.
Okay.
So, section one, the substance
of value abstract labor,
the magnitude of value,
socially necessary labor time.
Section one begins with an analysis
of a commodity as a general
system of commodity exchange,
and this general system is assumed
to be mutually consistent,
A is equal to B, and B is equal
to C, and A is equal to C.
And this property of
mutual consistency implies
that commodities are treated objectively
as equivalent, exchange is
the exchange of equivalents.
Each commodity is in principle
equivalent with all other commodities.
And this relation of
equivalence in turn implies
that each commodity must possess
some common property and
possess this common property
in definite quantities that determine
the ratios in which commodities
are equivalent with one another.
Marx discusses an example of a relation
of equality between two commodities,
the famous corn and iron example,
which he expressed in terms
of an equation, right?
Emphasizes the
relation of equality between commodities,
Marx says "whatever their
relation of exchange may be,
"it can always be represented
by an equation," right?
In which a given quantity of corn
is equated with some quantity of a buyer.
So, what does this equation signify?
Marx says "it signifies
that a common element
"of identical magnitude
exists in both of these things
"in the two (indistinct)."
And Marx of course argued that
this common property of commodities,
that determines their exchange
values is abstract labor,
the substance of value.
Marx summarized his
derivation of abstract labor,
as the substance of value
in the following key passes.
So, let us look at the residue
of the products of labor.
So we're looking at a commodity here
considered within a system
of general commodity exchange, right?
So, what do we see, well,
we don't really see anything,
but we know, we now understand
that there is nothing left of them,
but what he calls a
phantom-like objectivity.
They are merely congealed
quantities of homogeneous human labor.
All these things now
tell us as we observe,
tell us is that human labor power
has been expended to produce human labor
is accumulated in them,
as crystals of this social substance
which is common to them
all they are values.
So, Marx described as we see the substance
of value as a phantom-like objectivity.
Because, this abstract labor
contained in commodities
is not directly observable as such.
It exists, it's contained
within commodities,
but it's not something we can observe
and we will come back to
this point in section three.
So, Marx's derivation then,
of abstract labor as
the substance of value
can consist of the following steps.
Each commodity is considered
to be an equal and equivalent
to all other commodities,
the relation of equality implies
that all commodities possess
a common property, right?
And this common property
is (indistinct), right?
So, that's the bare bones of
the derivation in section one.
And in the next paragraph,
after the summary,
Marx preview, is later
derivation of section three,
on money as the necessary
form of appearance
of this substance of value abstract labor.
And he noted, Marx noted in this preview,
we must first however,
we must first consider the nature
of value independently of
its form of appearance.
So first, we're just gonna
consider the commodity
in terms of abstract labor
and socially necessary labor time,
independently of money and prices.
And he says "the progress
of our investigation
"will bring us back to exchange value
"as the necessary mode of expression
"form of appearance of value.
"For the present, however,
"we must first consider
the nature of value
"independently of its form of appearance."
And also, independently of
any actual act of exchange,
because we're just observing
this commodity and its properties.
On next page that Marx define
the magnitude of value in units
of labor time, hours, days,
independently of its form of appearance,
in terms of money.
The quantity, the magnitude of value
is measured by its duration,
labor time and a particular
scale of hours or days.
And Marx clarified that
the hours of labor time
that constitute the magnitude of value
are not measured by actual
hours of concrete labor,
which would be observable,
but are instead measured in terms
of a social average, quantities of labor
or what he calls socially
necessary labor time
required to produce commodities.
His definition in a sentence,
socially necessary labor time
is the labor time required
to produce any use value
under the conditions of production,
normal for a given society,
and with the average degree
of skill and intensity
of labor prevalent in that society.
So, the magnitude of
value is a social average,
not any particular
individual quantity only.
And then in the next
paragraph Marx summarize
the very clearly what
exclusively determines
the magnitude of the value of any article
is therefore, the amount of
labor, socially necessary,
the labor time socially
necessary for its production.
So one other important
point in section one
that I didn't mention in my paper,
is that "socially necessary
labor time," Marx says,
"varies inversely with
the productivity of labor,
"I.e with the quantity of
a product produced per hour
"of abstract labor,"
and I will come back to
this point later as well.
So toward the end of section one, look,
thinking again about this
overall logical structure
and the three aspects of value,
toward the end, Marx summarizes
the argument thus far
in another preview, of section three
on the form of appearance,
with the following summary
of the logical structure of chapter one,
he says, "now we know the
substance of value," right?
"It is labor."
We know the measure of its
magnitude, it is labor time.
The form which stamps
value as exchange value
remains to be analyzed.
But before this, we need to
develop the characteristics
we have already found more fully.
Develop the substance
and magnitude more fully
in terms of labor time,
in terms of abstract labor
and socially necessary labor time,
before we go on to the formal appearance
of value in section three.
So, I think Marx is emphasizing
this logical structure,
which I think is very important.
Now, just a word about section two
which further develops the substance
and magnitude of value
prior to money and prices.
And he further clarifies
that the precise meaning
of the magnitude of value as
socially necessary labor time
in units of hours or days is,
he clarifies the assumption
about different skills
and how he treats skilled labor.
He states that the basic unit of measure
of socially necessary labor
time is simple unskilled labor
without special development.
And that then skilled labor is
treated in the following way,
one hour of skilled labor
is assumed to count in the determination
of the magnitude of value
as some of the coefficient
of one hour of simple unskilled labor,
Marx put it more complex labor counts
as intensify or rather multiply,
simple labor so that a smaller
quantity of complex labor
is considered equal to a larger quantity
of simple labor, right?
And this reduction is
assumed to have taken place
here in section two, right?
Prior to the derivation of
money in the form of appearance
in section three.
Under section three, again,
a section that's often overlooked,
but is very important because it links
the inner hidden essence of value
with the observable forms of appearance,
it's actually one of my favorite sections
that so much blood sweat and tears
that I have come to
appreciate it's significant.
So, as I mentioned, the
logic in section three
is a continuation of the
logic in sections one and two.
We have already seen that
Marx explicitly noted
in section one that
this logical continuity
between the sections.
So as previewed in section one,
section three derives
money as the necessary form
of appearance of the substance,
and magnitude of value
in sections one, two.
And very briefly summarize Marx's argument
in section three is as follows.
The necessity of money
arises from the fact that
the substance and magnitude of value
are not directly observable as such,
in units of labor time,
as already mentioned,
so, this is what Marx meant in section one
by Phantom-like objectively
means not observable.
Therefore, the question
addressed in section three
is the following.
How do the presupposed
unobservable quantities
of socially necessary labor
time contained in commodities
as previously derived,
how does socially necessary
labor time acquire
an objective observable form of appearance
so that the value of each
commodity can in fact,
in practice, be compared with the value
of all other commodities?
That's the subject that Marx promise
twice in subsequent to
return to as we have seen,
and the progress of boxes investigation
has indeed led back to exchange value
as the necessary form of appearance
of the substance and magnitude of value.
Marx posed his question in section three.
In the introduction to
section three, as follows,
he says "not an atom of matter,
"enters into the objectivity
of commodities, as values."
It is in this sense, the direct opposite
of course, the sentious
objectivities as physical objects.
Says, "we may twist, we're
analyzing this commodity,
"this representative commodity," right?
And he said,
"we may twist and turn
this commodity as we wish."
Right?
"It remains impossible to grasp,
"it remains impossible to observe it
"as a thing possessing value."
So, then Marx's general
answer in section three
to this important question of
how unobservable quantities
of abstract labor obtains
an observable form
of appearance is that the
quantity of abstract labor
of socially necessary labor
time in any given commodity
is objectively expressed
in terms of the physical
quantity of another commodity,
the equivalent commodity and
ultimately the money commodity
and this equivalent commodity
is equal to the given commodity
because it contains the same quantity
of socially necessary labor time.
So, by equating these two commodities
that have the same quantity of labor time,
the magnitude, substance
and magnitude of value
in the first commodity is expressed
in terms of the physical quantity
of the equivalent commodity
that contains the same
quantity of labor time.
Marx says, "we started from exchange value
"or the exchange relation
of commodities in order
"to track down the value that lay hidden
"unobservable within it,
"we must now return to this
form of appearance of value."
So, the logic is from the hidden
to the observable from the observable.
The observable form of appearance
is derived from the hidden
substance in magnitude of value.
And perhaps the clearest evidence
that section three presumes,
that each commodity
contains a definite quantity
of abstract labor, and that
these presumed quantities
of abstract labor are used to provide
a quantitative labor
theory of exchange value
is one subsection in particular,
of the simple form of value
that is entitled the
quantitative determinacy
of the relative form of value.
Pages 144 to 146 in the Penguin Edition.
A very important and often
overlooked subsection.
In this subsection Marx emphasized
that the abstract labor contained
in commodities is presupposed,
and it must be expressed not
only in qualitative terms
as the same kind of
homogeneous human labor,
but also must be expressed
in quantitative terms
as a definite quantity
of magnitude of value
contained in commodities,
socially necessary labor
time is a quantity.
And therefore, its
objective form of appearance
must also be quantity.
So, in this subsection it is clearly
and explicitly assumed that any commodity
says, contains a definite
quantity of human labor.
That's the presupposition.
"Equality of linen and coats" Marx says,
"presupposes the presence of exactly
"as much of the substance of value
"or the same quantity of labor time
"in the two commodities."
This subsection also discusses
how the quantitative
expression of the linen
in terms of the exchange value with coats,
changes the quantitative
expression of the value
of the linen in terms of
the quantity of coats,
this quantitative ratio
changes if the labor time
and the quantity in either the linen
or the coat changes.
The presupposed quantities
of labor time change,
Marx discusses this, for cases, right?
First, the labor time required to produce
the linen changes, then
the labor time required
to produce the coat changes
and then both together
and then in different directions.
But in each case,
the labor time contained
in the commodities
is presupposed, and that
then determines the exchange.
So, I have an extensive excerpt
from this subsection in my paper.
And I will come back
to this later as well.
But the basic logic I think,
is very clear from the
presuppose labor times
in production to exchange
values in exchange.
So, these conclusions with respect,
this is in a subsection of
the simple form of value.
But the same conclusions apply as well
to the expanded form of value,
the general form of value,
and ultimately the money form
of value and money prices,
money prices are determined
by relative quantities
of labor time and production,
and changes in exchange values
are determined by changes
in these relative quantities
of labor time required to produce
a given commodity and equivalent.
In subsection C, of section three,
the general form of value,
is defined in terms of equations,
emphasize the relation of equality
between the relative and
the equivalent forms.
One coat is equal to 20 yards of linen,
or 10 pounds of (indistinct)
equal to 20 pounds of linen
or 40 pounds of cotton
is equal to 20 pounds
of linen, etc, right?
So all these equations presuppose
that the two commodities on
either side of the equation
contain the same property and contain
an equal magnitude of the same commodity.
That's what an equation means.
And Marx emphasized again,
in this section that the
general form of value
is not only quality,
it's not only an expression
of abstract labor
as a common property,
but that this expression of
value is quantitative, right?
And expresses this in this general form
of value when all commodities are counted.
Now, finally, as
comparable, with the linen,
all commodities appear not
only as qualitatively equal,
as value in general,
but also as values of quantitatively
comparable magnitudes.
So, section D of subsection
D of section three
is entitled the money form of value.
And in this subsection,
the price of a commodity is defined
as the exchange value of a given commodity
with the money commodity.
And this price is determined as before,
by the relative quantities of labor time,
presupposed to be contained
in the given commodity,
and the money commodity.
So the price of a
commodity in terms of gold,
is the quantity of gold, right?
A physical quantity, a quantity of gold,
that contains the same
amount of labor time
as the given commodity whose
price is being determined.
And here there's another set of equations
similar to the equations
for the general form of value,
except that the equivalent
commodity is gold,
rather than linen,
so there's a gold price for each
and every other commodity,
which of course presumes
that gold and each
of the other commodities,
contain the same quantity
socially necessary.
Then, in the first edition of Volume I,
unfortunately, not in late,
Marx concluded his derivation of money
and prices as the necessary
form of appearance of value
by emphasizing once again,
the overall logical structure here,
and that the form of value what he says,
arises out of, or is derived from
the substance and the magnitude of value.
Marx says, "what was decisively important
"was to discover the
inner necessary connection
"between value form, value substance
"and value amount," right?
"And express conceptually," he says,
"to prove that the value form arises
"out of the value concept."
Right?
So I think these many
passages in chapter one,
provide very strong,
unambiguous textual evidence
to support the interpretation.
Interpretation that chapter one
presupposes that individual commodities
contain definite quantities of socially
necessary labor time as derived
in sections one and two.
And then section three
derives money prices
as the necessary form of appearance
of these quantities of presupposed
quantities of abstract labor.
That's the inner necessary connection
between sections one and
two and three of chapter one
and that's the overall logical structure
of Marx's labor theory of value and money
and abstract prices in chapter one.
Okay, how am I doing in time?
- You're doing great.
- Okay, so then I'll
take the time I have left
to discuss this most important aspect,
these differences of
interpretation between
Michael and myself and and I will suggest
a possibility perhaps, for
some maybe (indistinct).
And that issue has to do
with the determination
of the magnitude of value, right?
And is the magnitude of value
socially necessary labor time,
is that determined entirely in production,
or also at least in part
in exchange and depends on
the demand on the market
for individual commodity,
so this is really one of the
most controversial issues
among Marxian economists in
general in recent decades.
Michael's interpretation as I understand,
it comes out of the
(indistinct) reading in Germany,
which has evolved in
the rest of the world,
in terms of value form,
the so-called value form,
interpretation of Marx's theory,
this so-called value form
interpretation has become
popular in recent decades.
And its proponents argue that
socially necessary labor time
is not determined solely
by average labor time
in production, but also depends
in part on social demand on the market.
And Michael is a prominent proponent
of this value form interpretation
Michael wrote in the introduction
in his introduction to "Capital" book,
labor time expended in production
as well as for the satisfaction
of monetary social
demand, constitutes value.
Turning the sentence,
value is constituted both
by the labor expended in production
and the satisfaction of monetary demand.
So first I wanna review again,
some of the main passages in chapter one,
that support my interpretation,
that socially necessary labor time
is determined by production.
- Could I interrupt you for a sec?
- [Fred] Yeah.
- I just wanna ask you a
question that might open up this
disagreement or almost agreement
to everyone who's joining us,
what would you say the stakes are
of your interpretation, his interpretation
and the disagreement?
What's at stake there really,
aside from the proofs
one way or the other?
- Well, I think, first of all,
just being what I'm trying to be,
as a true is possible to Marx's text,
and that itself is a first objective.
I also think it eventually the differences
have to do with whether
Marx's theory is a theory of,
at least in part of
equilibrium prices, right?
Or non-equilibrium prices,
and what's the relative importance?
And that's also been a
kind of separate discussion
going on in Marxian scholarship
for a long time, right?
But what I think is not
very clearly and widely
recognized and including by myself,
until really working on this paper, right?
Is the connection
between those two issues.
So is Marx's theory a bad kind of,
well, I mean, I would say Marx's theory
is mainly about surplus value, right?
But then equilibrium prices or
assume in order and explain
in order ultimately not to
explain equilibrium prices,
but to explain surplus value
- And how does it change our
understanding of surplus value
to think that value is created
and gets its magnitude
in the production process
with no additional inputs?
- Okay, the Marx's
theory of surplus value,
the inner law as he called it,
surplus value is determined
by surplus labor, right?
Surplus labor in production
and a clear strong conclusion
of exploitation, right?
But, if surplus value also
depends on the market, right?
On demand, that is what Marx called
a distracting influence, right?
And is a less strong
theory of the inner law
of surplus value and exploit.
It brings in distractions, right?
- That's very helpful, I appreciate it,
I know that line of thinking
to some degree that if
value is all created
in production, then it strengthens
the revolutionary position
of the proletariat
or makes exploitation a graver issue
or a more emphatic problem in capital.
So, I appreciate your clarifying that.
- Okay, and we can come back.
- Derail your presentation,
so you're welcome to go along with it.
- Okay, thank you.
So, let me just review a
few of the key quotations.
So we'll have my interpretation,
is we saw Marx define
socially necessary labor time,
as the labor time required to produce
any use value, under the
conditions of production,
normal for a given society
and with the average degree
of skill and intensity
of labor prevalent in that society.
The next paragraph Marx summarize,
what exclusively determines the magnitude
and value of any article,
is therefore the labor time
socially necessary for
its production, right?
So, nothing is said here
about exchange and demand,
what exclusively determines
socially necessary labor time
is the average labor time in production.
And coming back to the issue
of the inverse relationship between
the magnitude of value and
the productivity of labor,
toward the end of section one,
Marx discussed this relationship
and he said "the value of a commodity
"will therefore remain constant,
"if the value would remain constant,
"if the labor time
required for its production
"also remain constant," right?
So, even though supply and demand
may be changing around
all over the place, right?
If the quantity required for
its production is constant,
the value is constant, right?
But the ladder changes,
the productivity changes,
well, value changes with every variation
in the productivity of labor.
And he says,
"the productivity of labor is determined
"by various circumstances,
"the average amount of
skill of the workman,
"the state of science, the degree
"of its practical application,
"the social organization of production,
"the extent and capabilities
of the means of production,
"by physical conditions, etc."
Right?
So, these are
characteristics of production
that affect socially necessary labor time.
In general, the greater
the productivity of labor,
the less is the labor time required
to produce that article
and the less therefore is
the value and vice versa.
He says, "the value of
a commodity therefore,
"varies inversely with the
"productivity of the
labor in (indistinct)."
Well, I also wanted to
quote from that subsection
on the quantitative determination
of the form of value,
but I must have misplaced that page.
But it's again, I hope you
will look at it, right?
Page 144, five and six.
This is the labor times are presupposed,
and that then determines
the relative form.
- Do you feel like there's enough evidence
on the table to rest
your case temporarily?
- Oh, yes, yes, yes.
I also wanted to discuss the value form.
Sorry, I lost my page there.
Okay.
So the value form interpretation,
in contrast, right?
Argues that if supply
is greater than demand
in an industry, then the
price of the commodity
will fall and the socially
necessary labor time
will also be reduced, right?
Because of the insufficient social demand,
even though even if the average labor time
in production remains the same.
However, and this is the point
we touched on a minute ago,
I argue that Marx's theory in capital,
generally assumes that supply
is equal to demand, right?
And so assumes a way that case
except for a few asides here and there.
In other words, Marx's
theory of value and capital
is not about the daily
fluctuation of market prices,
but is instead about the center of gravity
of those market prices.
The equilibrium prices,
the long run average
which are the centers
of gravity around which market prices.
The main question as I said,
in Marx's theory is to
explain surplus value
and the inner law of surplus
value with surplus labor,
and to consider fluctuations
due to supply and demand.
Marx argued at the end of chapter five
would be a distraction from discovering
and pinpointing the inner
law of surplus value.
So, I present more textual
evidence in my paper
to support this supplies equal to demand,
equilibrium interpretation
of Marx's theory of value,
and would be happy to discuss these later,
and I think the evidence is conclusive
that Marx is trying to explain
the inner laws of capitalism
and not the daily
fluctuations of market prices.
And since equilibrium prices
assume supply is equal demand,
then in that case, supply and demand
have no effect on the determination
of equilibrium prices.
Cancel each other out.
Equilibrium prices are determined
in that case solely by the fundamental
cause of average labor
times in production.
Supply and demand,
determine market prices,
not equilibrium prices.
Furthermore, if supply
is not equal to demand
in an industry, which is usually the case,
the market price of the commodity
will be different from
the equilibrium price,
but the equilibrium price
will nonetheless remain the same, right?
And will still be determined
by the average labor time in production
even though supply and
demand are not equal
and market prices are fluctuating around
the equilibrium price.
Equilibrium price will change only
if the average labor time
in production changes.
One more page.
Michael wrote in his book,
that socially necessary labor time
is determined by three reductions.
And this was actually very helpful to me.
One, reduction of unequal
productivities of labor
to average productivity
within each industry.
Two, the reduction of skilled labor
to unskilled labor in all industries
and three, the reduction
of supply to demand, right?
However, if it is assumed that supply is
equal to demand, then Michael's
reduction number three
of supply to demand is
nullified, plays no role, right?
And in this case, socially
necessary labor time
is determined by the first two reductions,
unequal productivities
to average productivity,
skilled labor to unskilled labor, right?
And these two remaining reductions
are characteristics of production
and determinants of
labor time in production.
Thus, if it is assumed that
supply is equal to demand
as Marx generally assumed in capital,
then demand and exchange have no effect
on the determination of
socially necessary labor time,
even with Michael's interpretation
of socially necessary labor time
because the supply is
assumed to be equal to demand
and that reduction is not necessary.
So, I hope Michael will agree that under
the assumption of supply is
equal to demand at least,
socially necessary labor
time depends only on the
average labor time in production.
And if supply is not equal to demand,
then we have I think, two
different interpretations
of socially necessary labor time,
which may in fact, be compatible,
be mutually compatible and
not mutually exclusive,
they apply to different cases, right?
One an equilibrium concept of
socially necessary labor time
determined by average
labor time in production
and independent of demand,
because you're assuming that away, right?
And secondly, a disequilibrium concept
of socially necessary.
Labor time received
through exchange, right?
Which also depends on important demand.
And it has occurred to me in recent weeks
while working on this paper
that maybe we agree on this point
more than I thought, right?
In the case of supply is equal demand,
I hope we can agree that
socially necessary labor time
is the average labor time in production,
which determines the
equilibrium price, right?
If so, then the disagreement
would really boil down to
in the case of supply,
not equal to demand.
What's the definition of
socially necessary labor time
and is the concept operative at all?
It seems to me that maybe
these two definitions,
I don't think Marx ever talked about this,
explicitly in terms of socially
necessary labor time anyway,
but I wanna search some more
and think some more about this.
That the equilibrium and
the disequilibrium concepts
of socially necessary labor
time may be mutually compatible.
And I think this would be
a significant agreement.
And, as I said, Michael's discussion
of the three reductions,
one of which is the reduction
of supply and demand,
I think, helped me realize
at least this possibility
of more of agreement.
If supply is equal to demand
then there are only two reductions,
both of which have to do with
labor time of reductions.
So I'll stop here for now
and give Michael a chance to respond
and see what other people have to say.
Thank you very much for your attention.
And I look forward to the discussion.
- Thank you, Fred.
Let's just take a minute
to thank Fred for his talk
before we get into the
beautiful family fight.
There's no better fights
and family fights,
and especially when
they're about scripture.
It turns out all sorts
of hermeneutic questions
are on the table now too, so I think--
- What sort of what questions?
- [Paul] Hermeneutic questions.
- Okay, yeah.
- But thank you very much
for your presentation.
I think Michael you'd like to respond
and you could take as much
time as you want to do that.
- This is dangerous
when you allow me these,
to take as much time as I'd want.
I try to make it briefly.
But first is the connection okay.
Can you understand me?
Okay.
So, first, I have to thank Fred
that he changed his original idea
of a paper and make such big efforts
to discuss my approach to value theory,
I think this is a very big appreciation
of my work and I'm very thankful for that,
that you have main
critical points is not bad
because I think in this point,
we will agree that critique
is the method to get progress,
nothing is final nothing is perfect.
So, we need critique and I appreciate
your critique on my points
and already in this short exchange,
we had the last days,
I learned a lot and maybe we will not come
to an agreement, but at least also for me,
it became clearer in which points
I have to argue more precise,
more exact, and this I learned by you.
So, I want to focus on the main point
we disagree is the magnitude of value
already determined by production
before the exchange process
or is the magnitude of
value not determined
by production alone and in (indistinct)
also not before the exchange process?
Already one person asked
before what is on stake,
what are the consequences
of these different interpretations?
And I think he not Fred the person
who asked came to the conclusion, okay,
it strengthens revolutionary
when everything
is rested in production,
I think this is rather independent
from any revolutionary activities
or from insights which lead to revolution,
but there is something on stake,
when everything already is
determined by production,
then at least in principle,
we can know everything,
we can know all the magnitude of value,
we can treat value not as an outcome
which emerges like Marx says in the back
of the producers, but we can
treat them as known amounts.
And exactly this, in Soviet Union
in the so-called real
socialism planning economy
was attempted, there was the theory of,
they called it the conscious
application of the law of value.
And this conscious application
exactly presupposed
that we know already by production
without an process of exchange,
what are the magnitudes of value
and this planning process
was an enormous failure.
So for this, the wrong theory they had.
And of course, not only this was wrong,
I don't want to reduce
all the failure of Soviet Union
to this single point.
But this point, also contributed to this.
It had some revival some years ago,
in the discussions of a
socialism of the 21st century,
when, for example, authors
like Paul (indistinct)
argued by the use of computer
now we have the technology to make use
of all these knowledge and we can use
this knowledge we have
from the production process
of commodity production
for a socialist system,
I think this is totally wrong.
And when you try to do a socialist system,
according to such assumptions,
it will be disastrous.
So indeed, there is something on stage.
It's not only a question of details,
or pure science, it has
political consequences.
- Michael, can I ask
you just on this point?
- [Michael] Yeah.
It seemed to me that Fred was saying that
as a manifestation of value,
exchange value allows you to know
what's determined in production.
Do you mean that when you say
you can't treat them as known amounts,
the magnitudes of value,
do you mean that they're actually
being determined in exchange,
or they're just coming
to be known in exchange.
I think there's a difference
between being determined and being known.
- Exactly it is a difference
and they not come to be
known before exchange,
they are not determined,
they are as Fred quoted me correctly,
they are determined by production
and circulation or
production and exchange,
production alone is not enough
to determine magnitude of value.
And it is not a question of knowledge.
I will explain this at once,
let me just do before one remark
about different levels of discussion.
We can discuss this question,
where magnitude of value
is determined on a hermeneutical level,
interpreting Marx texts,
what is the opinion of Marx,
but also we have to
discuss what is the reality
of commodity production
and commodity exchange
and in so far the hermeneutical level
is only a helper when we assume
that Marx did a very good analysis.
So, we must be clear about his analysis,
but the point which is decisive
is our analysis then of reality
and not the analysis of texts of Marx.
So, I think they have to
distinguish these two levels,
I will come briefly to
the level of reality
I take this as an abbreviation,
why do I think that magnitude of value
is not determined only by production,
just let us restrict to
these two determinations,
we agree, socially necessary labor time
and the reduction of complex
labor to simple labor.
Socially necessary labor
time is a kind of average,
there are different kind
of production processes as Marx discusses
this in chapter one,
the one producer is quicker
the other is slower,
but what contributes to this average
is not just what every producer is doing,
it contributes only that products,
which are brought to the market,
when there is super modern factory
with an extremely high productivity
but the products are
hindered to enter the market
or the owner of the factory decides
to sell these products abroad,
because he can receive
higher prices or whatever,
then this factory or the
labor in this factory
will not contribute to this
average socially necessary labor time.
So by looking only on the production side,
we don't know really what contributes
to this average,
and even more clear,
it becomes when we look to the
reduction of complex labor,
to simple labor, it is
not only one reduction,
you have a lot of different
kinds of complex labor,
all of them must be
reduced to simple labor,
let us say, one hour
of labor of a craftsman
is reduced to three hours of simple labor,
five hour labor of...
One hour labor of an engineer
is reduced to five hours of simple labor.
But where does this reduction come from,
easy determined by production.
I don't know not even a theory
who explains this reduction
by production itself,
Marx speaks of a social process
in the second subsection of chapter one,
and in chapter seven, in the
last footnote of this chapter,
he stresses that this
reduction also depends
of social prejudice, for example,
that it comes out in a historical process.
And we have very striking examples,
that for example, the
such branches of work,
where women dominate as workers,
usually such branches count
less in this reduction,
it is not a question of the
pure complexity of labor
or of the production process,
it is also the part of social evaluation
and this is beyond the production process.
In so far,
I think it is impossible
to determine the magnitude
of value only by production.
I don't want to go deep in the question
of demand and supply, which has, I think,
nothing to do with the two
points I just mentioned.
But I want to stress one point,
it is true that Marx
later in "Capital" says,
"I presuppose demand and supply equals"
and by this he can abstract
from a lot of problems,
but what is the demand and
the supply which equals.
How is demand and supply determined?
This we must discuss
before we can assume supply
and demand equals.
And I think what Marx is
doing in the third chapter
he gives a second meaning to
socially necessary labor time.
And this second meaning then defines
what is demand and only then
we can discuss or we can
presuppose demand and supply
we assume that it is equal,
but, okay this is another point.
Now, I want shortly to come
to the hermeneutical level,
what is Marx telling us?
I think indeed, we have
to look to the logic
of Marx argumentation,
as Fred also stressed,
I would say we have to be clear,
what in the first three
chapters, Marx is doing,
what is the object, what
Marx wants to research
in the first three chapters of Volume I.
I think it is commodity circulation.
This complicated process
of commodity circulation,
commodity against money,
money against commodity,
commodity against money and so on,
this permanent intersection
is reduced by Marx
in a first step of abstraction
to the exchange process,
commodity owners exchange commodities,
and the core of the analysis
of this exchange process
is the exchange relation,
which Marx analyzes in chapter one.
So, when we read "Capital,"
we do the journey backwards,
we start with the most abstract core,
the exchange relation of two commodities.
In chapter two we include
the commodity owners
we come to the exchange process.
And in chapter three,
we see the intersection and interference
of all the exchange
processes in the circulation
in the commodity circulation.
So, exchange,
(clears throat)
sorry my voice is not
in a good condition in the moment.
So, what Marx analyzes
as exchange relation
is the most abstract core
of the circulation process of commodities.
And this exchange relation,
he dissects like an anatomist.
Fred gave the nice quote where Marx says,
"we have to consider
value independently from,"
I think it's a form of
appearance of value form.
I stress that Marx wrote,
we have to consider,
he doesn't say value exists
independently from value form.
He says, we have to consider it.
And so I think Marx behaves
like an anatomist who wants
to analyze the human body.
And he has to start with certain organs.
So maybe he starts with the heart,
which is pumping blood,
and then comes to the lung,
which is filling the blood with oxygen.
But this sequence of explanation
is not identical with
a sequence of existence
that first the heart exists.
And then after a while, the lung exists.
And then after a while,
something else exists.
So what I think is a mistake of Fred,
is to identify the sequence of explanation
we find in Marx, with a
sequence of existence,
a sequence in time.
And also, I think it's a mistake
to see in the sequence of time,
causal relationship, a causality from
what he thinks is fast to that
what he thinks comes later.
At the beginning of his paper,
he gives this nice quote
from the first edition
that Marx said I wanted to prove
that value form arises
from the value concept.
This is a very Hegelian wording
and Marx himself said sometimes,
he is pocketing with Hegelian terminology,
he also becomes clear that
this terminology arises
from is not a temporal sequence.
When you read Hegel's signs of logic,
you have the essence and the necessity
that the essence needs
a form of appearance.
But of course, Hegel nowhere argues
that essence exists first in time,
and then after a while
it receives a form of appearance,
and I think the same is true for value
and value form as form of appearance,
they can only exist simultaneously.
So, what Marx is doing
in the first chapter,
he is dissecting the exchange relation,
he talks about value,
but value inside the exchange relation,
not outside the exchange relation.
So, this is one important difference
in the hermeneutics,
in the interpretation.
I will just briefly
mention another difference.
Now, Fred didn't mention
it in his lecture,
but he mentioned it in the paper,
he sent me and I suppose
also it was distributed
to the audience,
where the point is,
what means the common
in the phrase that labor
is the common social substance of value.
Fred, absolutely correctly,
quotes my interpretation that there
are two different ways
to interpret this common.
Common can mean that
two things independently
from each other process a property
or it can mean that
common means they share
this property, and my interpretation
is the second one, they share it.
And here is the point I also want to give
some textual evidence for my approach,
for the approach that
also Marx had in mind,
this meaning of common
as a shared property
inside the exchange relation.
There is a difference between the wording
of the first edition and
wording of the second edition,
which is totally lost in the
existing English translations.
When you read the first translation,
other than translation of the
first edition of "Capital,"
which also Fred quotes.
You can read in the
translation of (indistinct),
the common social substance
which merely manifests itself differently
in different use values, is labor,
in the second edition, you can
read a very similar sentence
in the translation of
Ben Fowkes as crystals
of this social substance,
which is common to them
all they have values.
In both English sentences,
we have the word common,
but in German Marx changed the words.
In the first edition, the
word he used was Gemeinsam
and for Gemeinsam, common
is a proper translation.
In the second edition, Marx
used the word Gemeinschaft leash
and here, common is a
very poor translation.
Gemeinschaft leash comes from the noun
Gemeinschaft, community.
Gemeinschaft leash, you have something
when the community has it.
So, that Marx changed
from Gemeinsam, common,
to gemeinschaft leash in community for me
is very clear sign that he saw
the value substance as something
which is only existing when there is
a relation between the two commodities
and this relation is in
the exchange relation.
In the exchange relation,
we can say the one commodity
has a magnitude of value
and the other commodity
has a magnitude of value.
With this I agree with Fred,
but outside this relation,
you cannot speak about
magnitudes of value.
So, with this I want also to close
my answer to Fred, thank you very much.
- Thank you, Michael.
We appreciate your coming back.
And your being such a good support
and giving us a lot to think about.
It's great when we have family fights,
it's great when hermeneutic
questions get opened up.
It's always interesting to me when people
use the the hagiographical move,
which is this is what Marx was saying.
And when people use the move,
well, even if he was saying
that he might not be right.
There's these ways of looking
at the text are different
and they're both important
and they move around in
different people's readings.
Fred, I'm gonna give the
microphone over to you.
Do you want to respond?
- A few responses I also
wanna hear from other people.
So let's start with the first point about
the magnitude of value cannot
be known in production.
And I'm not arguing that the magnitude
of value social necessary labor time.
It can be known in production.
I argue that Marx assumes
that it exist in production
in a system of commodity production,
we're not, so it's produced for exchange.
Right?
So it's already in production,
it's in an exchange relationship.
It's in an economy based on
commodity exchange, right?
So I'm certainly not saying that
it is known or has to be known, right?
I mean, it exists.
And my point is that I stressed
that section three is about,
it's not knowable in production,
it's not knowable in
terms of abstract labor.
That's why money is necessary, right?
So I think that kind of
misses my point all together,
that socially necessary labor time
in order to exist, but is unknown, right?
Is assumed to exist, right?
And in order to become known, right?
It has to express its hidden value
in the observable form of money.
So I think you are conflating
know and exist, right?
And I'm not conflating that,
I'm emphasizing that that's not the case.
That value is not known until exchange,
until the form of appearance, right?
Just the form of appearance.
I think the reference to
the USSR is not relevant.
As I'm not, this is a
theory of capitalism, right?
And it was attempted
to be applied in crude
ways to a planned economy,
but I don't think that has anything to do
with the validity or lack
thereof of Marx's theory,
certainly not my interpretation.
And on simultaneity of
everything in capitalism,
I think the body analogy
is not a good one.
Because Marx is analyzing
capitalism with in,
which is a process, right?
And the process is the
circuit of capital, right?
And the circuit of capital goes
through distinct phases, right?
Capital exists first on the market,
in the form of money
used to purchase means
of production and labor power,
then capital exist in production, right?
Where Marx says exclusively
a capitalist formed, right?
Surplus value is produced, right?
And then, right?
Consecutively in time, there is the return
to the market and the sale of the markets
of the products produced
and the realization
of the value produced, right?
I'm not saying that value is
known in production, right?
I'm saying value is produced.
Production and then subsequently,
I mean, I'm not saying that simultaneous
determination is not possible
in other cases, I'm saying
that exchange value, right?
Is determined by production.
Now, in that sequence, production
comes before sale, right?
And so, in that particular case,
in that particular reality,
there is temporal sequence
of causation, right?
Because we're talking about
a process, (indistinct)
So I think I'll stop there for now
and maybe come back,
but I like to hear from other people too.
- Right.
So why don't we open up
the chat for questions
and maybe we can come back around
to these distinctions through people's,
other people's minds.
There might have been
some comments earlier on
but if you wanna make a comment,
would you put it back in?
Now repost and also post your questions.
Okay, could we go to
Manuel Casique Herrera.
Audrey would you open Manuel's mic?
Manuel, if you're there,
you could ask your question.
Do we have you?
- [Manuel] Yeah.
Can you hear me?
- [Paul] Yes.
- [Manuel] Having to speak in English
in front of a whole audience.
So I'm gonna try really
hard to do my best.
My question is like,
is obvious that market
prices have oscillations
and those oscillations
if after private labor
is the substance of all the value produce
and all the surplus value
is the same remain the same.
So, when market prices oscillate,
capitalists can compete each other
to appropriate surplus value produced
by other capitalist
because their surplus value pool remains
always the same, despite
the prices oscillations.
What would you think of that?
- Thank you, Manuel
was a perfect English
rendition of your question.
Fred, do you want to respond?
- Well, capitalist would
mean that was the subject
of Volume III, that is
the subject of Volume III,
the distribution of surplus value, right?
And some capitalists
are able to appropriate
more surplus value than others
for various market power reasons, right?
But that is a subsequent division
of the surplus value that
is produced by workers.
So it's a part of the theory,
it can be incorporated in a theory,
but because one capitalist appropriates
more surplus value that another capitalist
doesn't mean the capitalist
produced that surplus value.
The total surplus value
comes from the surplus
labor of workers,
and then that's divided up
in various competitive ways.
I hope that helps.
- Okay, we have a question from Bilal.
Can we open the Bilal's mic?
Bilal (indistinct)
undergraduate in the seminar.
Welcome.
- [Bilal] Thank you.
Thank you, Professor Moseley
for your interesting comments.
I had a question about
inflation in particular,
you mentioned how Marx's
theory explains the inner
laws of capitalism and
not minor fluctuations.
But one of the inner laws
is the sustained increase
in gender price level that we've seen,
constantly increasing inflation.
So I was wondering whether
your interpretation of Marx
maybe just Marx's writings itself,
sort of tie in and can explain
this in a law of capitalism.
Or is it something that I don't know,
a lot of Marxist theory that I've seen
just somehow overlooks inflation.
I'm not really sure how
Marx explains a lot of it.
- Well, that's a good kind
of contemporary question.
Obviously.
And, in Marx's theory, in "Capital,"
he assumes that money
is a commodity, right?
Some people argue money
has to be a commodity,
and I don't think that's true, right?
But Marx's theory has to be, I think,
updated and elaborated
to take into account
the fact that money is no
longer a commodity like gold.
Right?
So I think that's an
important current task
of Marxian economics is to develop
a more complete theory
of non-commodity money.
I've done some work on that.
And I don't think it's the final answer.
But based on (indistinct)
when there was inconvertible,
fiat money in the late 18th
and early 20th century,
then, if too much money
is forced into circulation,
then prices will rise, right?
So that I think is at
least a starting point,
it's not the total answer.
And it requires much more development,
but also a change of the basic function
of definition of what money
is in capitalism today.
- Okay, thank you.
I'm going to read a question
from the chat from Andy Summers.
Is the disagreement in forming
the surplus value problem
actually related to appearance about
the nature of physical
labor versus cognitive labor
in the formation of a commodity socially
necessary labor time and
hence, its labor power.
Does value form analysis
solve that problem?
Also, doesn't this also resemble
the later historical
issue of monopoly capital
unaddressed by Marx, but
taken on by Baran and Sweezy.
Doesn't this also allow for the kinds
of issues brought up by analytic Marxism
in terms of inequality of distribution.
Referring to Ruma.
So the first question is about
the difference between
physical and cognitive labor
in I guess the calculation
of the magnitude
or the creation of the commodities value,
and the second is about.
- Monopoly capital.
- [Paul] Monopoly capital.
- Well, I think the question
about monopoly capitalists,
in my view, much easier to answer.
And again, I think that was
related to the previous question
that monopoly affects the
distribution of surplus, okay,
in my view, interpretation
of Marxist theory,
monopolies affect the
distribution of surplus value.
But unless that's affecting
wages in some way,
does not affect the production
of surplus value and the total amount
of surplus value that's produced, right?
So, this I would disagree
with Baran and Sweezy, right?
They thought monopoly capital actually
increase surplus value, right?
But I think a more
consistent interpretation
would be that monopolies
get a bigger share
of the total surplus value,
but in general, except
maybe on a smaller scale,
do not affect the production.
And the total amount.
- Over time as well monopolies
have to cede their monopoly
at a certain point.
Right?
It's a temporarily
bounded problem monopoly.
- Yeah, it's one aspect
of the competition.
And competition has to do with,
determines the distribution
of surplus value,
and that will certainly change over time.
The cognitive question, I
think, is another challenge.
I think obviously is value producing
so I mean, this would be one
one example of skilled labor.
And so the cognitive labor would
produce in an hour more value.
How much more value?
We don't know.
But that is what Marx's
theory would suggest.
Then the question is how
important is it to know
these reduction coefficients?
And I think it is of some importance,
but I mean, Marx said at
the end of chapter seven,
his theory of surplus value,
even though he didn't present any theory
of what determines those
reduction coefficient,
so to speak, instead, the same theory
applies to skilling, right?
That skilled labor is paid more, right?
But they're also produce
value at a higher rate.
And therefore, the basic theory
of surplus value still applies.
And I think that would
also apply to cognitive.
- Okay, I wanna invite anyone else
in the listenership, watchers, viewership
to pose some questions.
While you're doing that, I wanna
go back to something
that Michael brought up.
That needs a lot more exposition.
And I know, maybe he's done it elsewhere.
But I wanna ask you Fred
about his proposition that,
in fact, exchange enters
into the constitution
of socially necessary labor time.
That is, products that are produced
and not realized in exchange
don't get counted in the average.
So this is a backdoor way
and that doesn't have anything to do
with the supply demand problem.
What do you think about that?
- Well, I think the theory assumes
a system in which what
is produced is exchanged.
We're looking at a totality, in that case,
the company that sells elsewhere, right?
In another market, would that be included
in the determination of
socially necessary labor time,
is not a purely physical
thing in any country,
you do a weighted average
of the labor times
and determine socially
necessary labor time,
is goods that were
produced for this market.
And that they're the only
ones that go into the average.
I don't see a problem.
- Looks like there aren't
any other questions.
We wanna thank you for your presentation.
Invite you to not sign off
while we let everyone else go.
Let them thank you for coming
and presenting really important material.
So thank you.
- Thank you.
- Thank you also, it was
nice to meet Fred again.
(Fred laughs)
- Thanks for your comments as always,
and we will be in touch I'm sure.
- [Michael] Yeah.
(Fred laughs)
- Thank you, Michael.